(exhales)
- I don't know why I'm
like freakin' out so much.
(playful, romantic music)
- I'm worried in that I don't think
there's any that I have not done.
- I'm expecting, hopefully, to learn
something new about Cody.
- I'm wondering if I'm gonna find out
something very surprising.
- We're both pretty
honest, so I don't think
there will be too many surprises.
- Not a lot of skeletons in any closet.
- Never have I ever said "I
love you" without meaning it.
(gasps)
Oh no! (laughs)
- May have told some white lies.
- I think I have.
I think it was just someone
I was having sex with
and they said it was a turn on for them
and I was like, sure, let's
try it out, and it was fun.
- I say what I mean,
and I mean what I say.
- Have you ever fantasized about
a friend's significant other?
- I would definitely say
that there were like,
certainly times in high
school and otherwise,
where'd you'd just me like, man,
that'd be cool, wouldn't it?
- Have you ever shoplifted?
I'm a drag queen, I was
looking for a new bald cap
to go underneath my wig,
and I found that the bottoms
of pantyhose or tights work really well.
- Aren't those cheap anyway though?
I don't know.
- Yeah, that's why
I'm bad at it.
- You have?
What?
- Yes.
I shoplifted when I was
like three years old.
- Never have I ever forgotten
someone's name I've slept with.
Good for you.
It was like a one night stand sort of deal
and I didn't want them to
forget my name the next day,
I don't know.
So I was very adamant about making sure
they remembered my name, but in doing so,
I completely ignored
whatever their name was.
- Have you ever cheated on a partner?
- That's actually how
we ended up together.
- Have you ever faked an orgasm?
- In general, uh,
have I?
- What do you mean in general?
- I have not.
(gasps)
- I have faked an orgasm before,
but it was only because
I orgasmed too early.
- Never have I ever taken
someone's virginity.
- Really?
- Have you ever been to a strip club?
This actually we haven't
talked about, but, I have not.
- I have not either.
I was ready for you to say yes.
- Never have I ever had a threesome.
(laughs)
We have had a threesome with each other.
(laughing)
- Have you ever stolen
something from your partner?
- Ooh, you have?
What'd you steal?
- Their heart.
- The fake I love you was most surprising.
- I was not surprised.
- No me either, I'm so sorry, nope.
- We talk so much and we're
super honest, which is great.
- Something I learned about Alex
is you're just bad at stealing.